Speaker 1: Well, ladies and gentlemen, we got him.
The IRS has released Donald Trump's tax returns,
in fact, six years worth of tax returns to
the House committee that is involved in that
investigation. It has taken three years, but
it has finally happened. And now this becomes
a matter of watching for leaks. And of course,
I would never tell anyone to leak anything or to
disclose sensitive information or to do anything
wrong. I would just never do that. But I also
understand from an objective standpoint that the
possibility of a leak here is significant, and we
are going to be watching for that. CNBC Reports
IRS Gives Trump Tax Returns to House Committee
After three year legal battle. The final straw was
the Supreme Court saying, we're not going to block
the release of these tax returns. The article
points out the House Ways and Means Committee
has obtained two years worth of federal income
tax returns for former President Donald Trump,
just a week after the Supreme Court rejected
his effort to block that Democratic controlled
panel from getting those records from the IRS.
The committee has been seeking had been seeking
Trump's tax returns in 2019 when he was still
president. Trump broke decades of tradition by
refusing to publicly release his tax returns.
Now, remember that for a very long time, Trump
was insisting, as soon as my audits are done and
out of the last minute, I'm going to go ahead and
release everything. And the goalposts kept moving
and moving and moving. Here's just a little bit of
a reminder of that. This is more recent.
Speaker 2: Because.
Speaker 3: As you said, you spoke to your
accountant about potentially releasing your
taxes. Did he tell you when you can release
them? June seven is the deadline for when
you're going to release. I get treated.
Speaker 2: Worse than the Tea Party got
treated because you have a lot of people in there
deep down in the IRS, they treat me horribly. We
made a deal. It was all settled until I decided
to run for president. I get treated very badly
by the IRS, very unfairly. But we had a deal all
done. As soon as we're completed with the deal,
I want to release it. But it says.
Speaker 3: You just said you spoke to.
Speaker 1: Yeah, he didn't really intend to
release those tax returns. And quite frankly, once
it became clear that his followers didn't really
care, I understand why he didn't release them.
And we'll get in a moment to what we believe would
be in there. A few other notes here from the CNBC
report. A Treasury Department spokesperson told
NBC News, quote, Treasury has complied with last
week's court decision. The Treasury Department
is the parent of the IRS. The Ways and Means
Committee has said it. Wanted copies of Trump's
tax returns and the tax returns of Trump legal
entities for an inquiry into how the IRS audits
presidential tax returns. By law, the tax agency
audits the returns of a sitting president every
year. So it's a leak. Watch now what is most
likely in those tax returns? We've been building
and sort of tweaking our belief about this based
on what has become publicly available information
over time. I think the most likely revelations
from Trump's taxes would all be things that we
suspect or to some degree know already. Number
one, Trump is not as rich as he claims to be. It's
hard to imagine Trump being richer than he claims
to be and based on what people like Michael Cohen
and others have told us. Donald Trump has postured
to be higher on the Forbes richest list using all
sorts of different methods, and more than likely,
his taxes would show he's not actually as
rich as he is claimed to be. Number two,
Trump lies and that we know we know Trump lies.
He's the most dishonest president in the modern
political era. Number three, Trump probably has
debts that we might call sketchy or debts shady
or debts to entities or individuals that he
likely would not want us to know, and which
may potentially present a national security risk
even greater than that which we already believe
based on publicly available information. And I
think that that would be the those would be the
main revelations from Donald Trump's tax returns.
Now, one interesting other note I want to mention,
Donald Trump, as you know, exhausted just about
every he exhausted every means available to him to
try to block the release of these tax returns,
including going to the Supreme Court. And it
ultimately did not work. Now, we can colloquially
say, would someone who has nothing to hide? Work
this hard to hide their tax returns? Well, I don't
know. A lot of it could just be ego. Trump doesn't
want the world to know beyond any doubt that he's
not as rich as he claims to be. But one of the
arguments that through his lawyers Donald Trump
made to the Supreme Court was that no Congress
has ever wielded its legislative powers to demand
a president's tax returns. And that continues to
be a theme this has no president has ever had his
home raided by the FBI. Trump said that after the
search warrant was executed in Mar a Lago. These
things haven't happened before because we've
never needed to see them happen before. Donald
Trump. Donald Trump so flouted the norms of the
presidency that when you get unprecedented inputs,
you end up with unprecedented outputs. Outputs,
and it's really that simple. Do Republicans even
care? I don't think so. I don't know that they
ever really cared. If they cared, they might not
have voted for Donald Trump to begin with when
he didn't release his tax returns and made it
clear he didn't really plan to. And the audit
story was completely made up. So the House Ways
and Means Committee has Trump's taxes six years
worth. We now will wait very patiently
to see out of genuine curiosity whether
those tax returns leak. We're going to take a
very quick break and be back right after this.